well today we're going to be speaking
with mike cargile mike cargile is
running for congress in california's
35th congressional district
uh i believe mike you're the only
congressional candidate this cycle who
has been unendorsed by the republican
party is that is that a correct
credential that you have
yes actually i am the only congressional
candidate in the nation
who's been unendorsed twice now by the
republican party for
being what they consider too
conservative so give me any was there
communication did they tell you on what
issues you're just too far to the right
no actually they scrolled we a few weeks
ago they had an unendorsement meeting of
their board of directors yeah and they
said here you've got two minutes to talk
and i said talk about what
what do you want to talk about and they
said well watch this and they rolled
four minutes
of memes off of facebook that go all the
way back to 2018
and i knew where this came from because
this was how george soros had attacked
me in the last cycle oh soros is going
after you he has and and so the
republican party is using the soros
playbook uh he came after me with media
matters and axios last time
would you say soros has infiltrated the
republican establishment at this point
yes
wow yes so they uh they came after me
and tried to now remember back in 2020
this was the world of blm riots and
things like that so he had unearthed a a
conversation a private conversation i
had had with a friend of mine
about the use or the prevalent use of
the n-word in rap music and i said
that's all so we're typing this out and
i said that's all they're doing right
now is building the songs around the
n-word and i typed the n-word out
expressing you know my concern because
not a word you would ever use other than
citing it of course
correct correct but but you have when
you're having a conversation in
messenger you have to type it out right
and so they found this and said oh look
he's a racist he's using the n-word and
that was the narrative and the new york
times picked it up la times boston
you know everywhere suddenly because of
the environment at that time
so mike i don't want to let this slip
because this is mind-blowing
george soros who at the time of i guess
when this happened was 90 i think he's
92 now 90 year old george soros
obtained a private text communication
that you had with someone else
bemoaning the use of the n-word in rap
music is that right
yes wow that is an incredible story and
then they they take it and they go look
see white guy
writes out the n-word and he's a racist
and then
you know then they just sort of cast and
that's probably it's almost unbelievable
to be perfectly frank i think many in my
audience will struggle to believe that
well it's what happened and it was what
was regurgitated
by the california republican party a
couple weeks ago
as as further evidence and they they
said publicly in their meeting uh anyone
can can look this up because it's all
over the internet now what they did to
me but but they said how did this guy
make it through the primary we
unendorsed him in 2020 and here he is
again and we're having to unendorse him
again